bon
oui
bonjour et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv la
télé du conseil départemental alors
aujourd'hui dans notre émission vivre
ensemble on va essayer de mieux
comprendre donc le rôle des pmi dans la
vie des réunionnais pour ce faire je
reçois sur ce plateau le dr
jean-françois seule chine qui est
médecin chef au service de pmi bonjour
docteur on reçoit également deux
puéricultrices donc nathalie payet qui
exerce à la pmi du port et christine
beaumont qui exerce à la permis de
sainte marie alors bonjour à tous les
trois alors deux tours la protection
infantile et maternelle la maternelle et
infantile plus tôt et l'accompagnement
des familles est un axe fort de la
politique départementale alors en quoi
consiste cette mission au niveau des
missions de la pmi proprement dite c'est
une mission qu'il ya beaucoup de
missions donc de façon globale
ce que les gens connaissent plus le prix
tant au niveau de la pmi protection
maternelle infantile ce sont avant tout
les consultations c'est à dire que la
paix mire effectue toujours des
consultations de nourrissons du premier
temps mais également des consultations
donc de planning familial c'est à dire
pour les jeunes ou bien pour les femmes
qui viennent pour demander la pilule ou
bien pour avoir une autre méthode de
contraception il ya également dans
l'émission des permis des bilans de
santé en école maternelle qui consiste
principalement à effectuer donc un
examen médical au niveau des enfants de
la petite section donc de tous les
enfants de trois à quatre ans dans mon
école maternelle mais il ya également
d'autres commissions beaucoup plus
diverses variées telles que les visites
d'établissements au niveau des
structures d'accueil de jeunes enfants
ce qu'on appelle les crèches des
garderies les visites également dans des
dents les ce qu'on appelle les accueils
collectifs de mineurs c'est à dire les
centres aérés ce que les gens appellent
les centres de loisirs est également
dans d'autres cadres des missions de
prévention beaucoup plus spécifique et
prévention dans le cadre petite enfance
surtout au niveau donc eu des troubles
de parentalité d'accord alors nous avons
nous ont permis des équipes
pluridisciplinaires on a des médecins
des sages femmes
première des éducatrices de jeunes
enfants des secrétaires des auxiliaires
de puériculture et des infirmières
puéricultrices
alors vous vous exercez d'intel payet
sur la permis du port ça consiste un peu
en quoi votre mission au quotidien ça se
passe comment alors notre mission
première c'est de faire de la prévention
médico social auprès des enfants de la
naissance jusqu'à 6 ans donc comme
docteur chan qui me l'a dit il ya en
premier donc les consultations ont fait
avec le médecin souvent donc on fait le
suivi du développement de l'enfant de
ses besoins nous accompagnons donc les
parents dans le
le rôle parental on fait aussi des
actions collectives
avec des petits ateliers sur divers
thèmes en fonction du moment donc comme
c'est la fête des pères ou des mères
on peut faire des ateliers sur
l'allaitement maternel tout ça dans la
vraiment pour une prévention globale
primaire nous avons un regard
particulier sur les mamans vulnérables
les enfants prématurés et autant
d'enfants que c'est en retard de
croissance intra utérin nous effectuons
également des visites à domicile
donc pour tout le monde pas seulement
pour ces mamans en difficulté
il ya également après un vol au niveau
des assistantes maternelles donc les
puéricultrices fonds a suivi des
assistants maternels
elle effectue les renouvellement
d'agrément les suivis des agréments
et également comme docteur gilles a dit
sur les structures d'accueil de jeunes
enfants nous allons avec le médecin en
partenariat donc faire lé renouvellement
d'agrément de ces structures est ce que
l'émission sur sept maris sont à peu
près les mêmes vous fait à peu près la
même chose et est ce que ça se passe au
quotidien oui c'est vraiment c'est très
semblable c'est très semblable même sur
tout le département
nous avons aussi un rôle au niveau des
informations préoccupantes d'enfants en
danger on travaille là en partenariat
avec nos collègues de la zone
on a aussi un rôle au niveau de tout ce
qui peut être prise en charge des mamans
qui peuvent être en difficulté vers
différents moments pour leur montrer
pour leur excès pour leur expliquer les
choses dans le cadre des visites à
domicile donc on peut être amené à
préparer un biberon on peut être amené à
fond là il ya vraiment c'est très très
vaste notre travail est vraiment très
très l'instant alors justement pour
mieux comprendre le rôle votre rôle et
plus globalement les missions la pmi on
va se rendre à la pmi dans une pme
s'indigne la place joffre et on regarde
tout de suite ce reportage
delphine et son petit dernier nasser
sont en consultation aujourd'hui et la
pmi une visite qui commence par le
cabinet de la puéricultrice aujourd'hui
si drôle je suis là aujourd'hui
après une première prise de contact la
puéricultrice début de la consultation
le moment pour delphine de demander des
précisions sur l'état de santé de son
fils très bien comment ça se passe j'ai
les démos niveau alimentation mélange de
tout ça y est on a dénommé la
diversification à travers cette
consultation il s'agit aussi de vérifier
que la croissance de nasser se fait
normalement un échange qui permet à la
maman d'être rassurés ils se libèrent
les bras pour attraper les jouer voilà
il faut continuer les questions tombent
ou fou autour de l'alimentation est
souvent puisque il ya toute la phase
avait dire de diversification
alimentaire ou les enfants ou les
parents sont souvent inquiets sur ce que
doit manger leurs enfants quelle
quantité on doit leur donner donc tout
ça nous nous devons les idées dessus
elle leur donnait des conseils adaptés
et ensuite c'est souvent aussi de
l'ordre du sommeil delphine m ce
contexte particulier avec la
puéricultrice et plus globalement les
personnes qui travaillent à la pmi pour
preuve nécessaire et le troisième de ces
enfants est suivi pour la structure la
famille c'est plus convivial on compte
beaucoup de gens il y avait déjà en
rencontre d'avoir une puéricultrice et
ensuite on rencontre le médecin donc on
a le temps de discuter avec la paix du
christ je ne faisais pas de questions
ainsi le médecin est là plutôt pour les
actes les soins donc ouais c'est assez
convivial c'est je préfère venir ici
après être passé entre les mains de la
puéricultrice et direction le cabinet du
médecin
avait fait voir les petites gens
ok il existe plusieurs pmi dans toute
l'île un service du conseil
départemental accessible à tous
on revient et on voit dans ce reportage
donc effectivement qu'il ya une suivi
des enfants des bébés et des mamans mais
où ici
une prise en charge des enfants et pour
revenir sur un point c'est il ya aussi
une prise en charge des enfants on dira
différents qui sont porteurs de handicap
en situation de handicap pour l'asie oui
les enfants avec particularités comme
peuvent l'être des enfants porteurs de
handicap d'une maladie ou d'une
prématurité font partie des enfants que
nous suivrons plus particulièrement
jusqu'à au moins six ans donc bien
souvent on repasse les dossiers à la sa
mère qui elle va les suivre dans le
cadre des bilans de santé puisqu'elle va
aller trop voir ces enfants là à ce
moment là quand y'a pas d'infirmière
pour séduire et curistes qui soit amené
à faire c'est bien de santé d'accord
justement alors en ce qui concerne ce ce
suivi il y avait bien sûr comme comme
base de travail le carnet de santé c'est
également la pmi qui le remet à la maman
et ce dès la naissance de l'enfant
puisque vous vous rendez directement pas
maternité
voilà c'est bien ça on se rend en
maternité en général une fois par
semaine ou vous présente les missions de
la pmi à chaque maman et le carnet de
santé il est délivré par la maternité
mais c'est le conseil général qui le met
ma disposition et c'est donc les
maternités au moment des naissances qui
le distribue et nous les puéricultrices
et une première approche on présente
l'émission et eon on voit les mamans et
qu'on va pouvoir revoir par la suite en
consultation visites à domicile en
général ils viennent parce que c'est
cesser ces mamans qui viennent en
famille ça ça leur enlève un coût
financier puisque si on se fait suivre
par effectivement déçu son coin par un
pédiatre ou se fait depuis paris
gynécologue je suppose que c'est un coup
et ça évite de la pmi et vite ce jeu de
répondre à dessus c'est à dire que il
faut dire que ces deux pmi services qui
est accessible à tous c'est à dire pas
comme certains peuvent le dire seulement
à des familles défavorisées
on accueille tout type de public donc on
a service public mais bien sûr il ya une
orientation particulière en faveur donc
des familles qui en ont le plus besoin
mais dans ce cadre
on a donc des familles dans les parents
peuvent être des conditions sociales
tout à fait différente et c'est une
grande richesse pour nous parce que nous
on veut dire que chaque enfant donc doit
avoir un suivi d'autant plus s'il a des
problèmes et dans le cas de la
prévention primaire dont je dire que ce
soit en école maternelle ont bilan de
santé par exemple tous les enfants sont
vus ce n'est pas un enfant qui est
stigmatisé et dans le cadre des visites
à la maternité également donc toutes les
femmes sont vus donc il ya vraiment un
panel qui est très large et qui
s'oriente vers vers tous et c'est ce à
quoi donc la pmi aspyr auxois un service
public pour toute famille mais orienté
quand même on le dit vers les familles
qui en ont le plus besoin
les permis sur
ce très variable c'est-à-dire en
fonction des pmi en fonction donc des
endroits où au niveau des maternités il
ya quand même des des passages beaucoup
plus fréquent au niveau de ma des
maternités donc l'après crise pour vous
dire que on voit pratiquement
là toutes les femmes qui accouchent donc
je veux dire c'est très très large donc
l'information elle est très général
après c'est un libre choix de la famille
d'aller donc soit vers son médecin
traitant soit venir aux pmi pour se
faire suivre tout en sachant que la pmi
à un rôle purement préventif c'est à
dire dès que l'enfant à une maladie
particulière en nous rions glaçant
médecin traitant ou vers le pédiatre moi
ce que j'ai retenu en préparant cette
émission c'est qu'ils les jeunes femmes
qui les mères qui viennent aux pmi 10 on
nous écoute on prend le temps de nous
écouter il ya vraiment des choses qu
effectivement de la paix m c'est la
richesse de la paix m nous avons le
temps et nous prenons et
avant que les gens arrivent à ce livre
il faut du temps donc c'est vraiment un
respect de l'autre du début à la fin
c'est à dire qu'il ya d'abord l'accueil
la secrétaire fait un travail
extrêmement important puisqu'elle
accueille les gens et après ils passent
pour les consultations et passoire la
firme ya peu un culte rice et là aussi
on retravaille l'accueil la réponse à
leurs questions et c est après il passe
voir le médecin et donc tout ce
cheminement là il se fait dans le
respect de l'individu c'est
indispensable c'est ça aussi notre
richesse mais c'est vrai que quand on
n'a pas l'habitude de l'extérieur on se
dit toujours mais en bien de
consultation les gens prennent un temps
infini ça veut dire quoi mais les
familles qui viennent les mères qui
viennent une base je sais qu'elle dit
trouvent leur compte parce qu'elle
revienne parce qu'elles ont besoin donc
d'être écouté elles ont besoin de
conseils parce que quand on a un petit
bout de chou qui vient d'arriver que
parfois on se dit mais voilà on est très
perdu et on se pose tous types de
questions et on a des familles qui
viennent en pmi qui viennent avec leur
leur petite liste là j'ai noté ça parce
que j'ai peur d'oublier je veux dire
numéro 2 des petites choses qui peuvent
paraître bête mais que en pratique on a
vraiment besoin de savoir parce qu'on
est vraiment démunis c'est indispensable
que toute question une réponse
c'est vraiment indispensable parce
qu'une maman angoisses et ça passe pas
qu après l'enfant mais son angoisse est
ce que la famille a vocation à être dans
les coins les plus reculés de la réunion
ben il s'est ainsi pas par définition
donc on doit intervenir partout c'est à
dire même si la pmi n'a pas des points
de consultation donc dans dans tous les
écarts ce qui est tout à fait normal
mais justement on a nous affirme épopée
rectrice c'est que nos oxygène
nourriture qui interviennent vraiment
dans les coins les plus éloignés de la
réunion parce que on considère que
chaque famille doit pouvoir bénéficier
des conseils de la pmi et quand elles
ont fait la demande
les perruques trice se déplace donc on
ne regarde pas si c'est à notre bout si
la visite va va durer toute l'après midi
je veux dire voila voila j'ai fini avec
vous alors vous vous êtes un choix
d'avoir
exercé travailler en paix amy oui tout à
fait il faut je pense qu'il faut
vraiment le vouloir c'est un travail de
prévention moi personnellement j'avais
travaillé longtemps à l'hôpital donc on
est plutôt dans le curatif est donc là
c'est vraiment faire de la prévention
pour que tout aille le mieux possible et
je suis très contente de travailler au
bn moi pareil
qu'est-ce que ça particulier alors des
shows pas cet échange avec la population
c'est génial ça vous requinque toute une
journée non mais c'est vrai les gens
vous donnent énormément
bon on est on est chez eux demain cela
quand on les voit à l'hôpital ou
ailleurs là c'est vraiment chez eux et
on arrive à gagner leur confiance en
faisant les visitons les voyons
régulièrement ils viennent à la pmi
également donc c'est vraiment rentrer un
petit peu dans l'intimité des gens et et
on a gagné leur confiance c'est comme ça
que va on fait du soutien à la
parentalité
pour être plus précis et avoir toutes
les infos utiles concernant l'accès aux
pmi de la réunion donc on écoute tout de
suite les docteurs yann qui donne prix
du litre
suffit qu'elle prenne son carnet de
santé et à la dernière page il ya les
coordonnées de la pmi de son secteur
avec l'adresse et le téléphone mais nous
avons aussi les puéricultrices et des
auxiliaires de puériculture qui vont en
maternité en contre et les mamans au
moment de l'accouchement et killer pas
d'émission de la pmi et qui est l'europe
est également un flyer avec les
coordonnées des pmi du secteur alors
juste pour information il ya des
horaires de réception des horaires de
consultation à ce qu'ont fait les
rappeler alors c'est de 8 heures à 16
heures tous les jours et puis jusqu'à
15h le vendredi
puisque nous sommes sans lui-même
oriente le conseil général
pour retrouver toutes les pellicules
sont sur le site du conseil général dans
le carnet de maternité on a également
tous les contacts et toutes les adresses
ben merci hein vous trois et on se
retrouve très bientôt sur notre 4 kg
pour une nouvelle émission vivant au
revoir
hop